To factor this expression, we first want to find the greatest common factor. We
can find the prime factorization of each of our terms. Now we want to look for
the lowest power of each factor that appears in each term. We can see that a
factor of 2 appears in each term and in fact there's two of them. So 2 squared
is a part of our greatest common factor. The next factor that we multiply into
our greatest common factor is 3. There's a power of 3 to the 1 for all of our
terms. We can not include x as a factor since it doesn't appear here, but we can
include a y. Y to the 1 would be part of our greatest common factor. When I
multiply all these factors together I get 12 y. That goes on the outside. When
we divide this first term by 12y, we're left with 2x. We can also see that in
our factors. If we take out 12y, then we're left with 2x. The second term is a
little bit more simple. We will just be left with x times y, and again, we see
that in our factors. The last term will be negative 3y squared. It's what we'll
get when we multiply the remaining factors together. So this expression has been
completely factored. We have one number times another number.